hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
2021's weather was unremarkable says the
met office but only because we're
getting used to a rapidly changing
planet
a u-turn in washington could mean
important progress for president biden's
climate agenda
and as gas prices soar and concerns over
supply continue how should the uk be
looking to secure its energy this winter
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we track the changes happening to our
world hear from those affected and
report on the race for solutions now sea
levels are rising more quickly and
warmer temperatures are the new normal
for britain that's according to an
annual review of last year's weather
from the met office although the report
says there was nothing remarkable about
the weather overall in 2021 this is all
in the context of climate change the
report goes on to explain that's because
our perception of what's normal is
changing
the report says temperatures last year
which should now be regarded as normal
would have been near record-breaking
just over 30 years ago
all of the uk's top 10 warmest years
have occurred this century since records
began back in 1884.
the met office says the rate of sea
level rise is increasing by around 16.5
centimeters since 1990.
it also suggests spring is coming
earlier raising concerns that plant and
animal life are not evolving quickly
enough to adapt sky's katarina vitovsky
has the story
today's met office report looks at last
year's weather but more crucially its
impact
2021 was another year in a pattern of
warming
that's changing things we take for
granted
spring is getting hotter and wetter and
the seasons are shifting now the warmer
weather has really sped up fruit
ripening and and nuts for me now what
that means is it sounds well what's the
problem with that but actually that
happening earlier can have a really
disastrous effect for wildlife because
they may not have the food source
available later in autumn when they need
it so there's real jeopardy for some
species here yeah there's real jeopardy
not we're in massive species decline
already
[Applause]
what's interesting about looking at last
year's weather is in some respects how
unremarkable it actually was in 2021
there were no extreme record highs but
why that is interesting is that if you
take that 12 months and look at it in a
broader context even without a record
high it was still one of the hottest
years on record
look at this at how much warmer 2021 was
and the average hottest day of the year
just a few decades ago
and remember today's report doesn't look
at this year 2022 that has already
changed the game entirely with the uk
average temperature exceeding 30 degrees
celsius for the first time ever
as climates change extremes become more
frequent last year saw storm irwin
batter parts of the uk with high winds
and snow eight months later just last
week it was that blistering heat
our natural world can adapt to gradual
change but shocks like extreme weather
in addition to our warming climate could
push some species too far to a point
beyond which they cannot recover
caterina over topsy sky news
well as you heard in katarina's report
the average temperatures in the uk are
rising every year and we're getting less
rain this month is not yet over but so
far it's been the driest july in england
since 1911 and the second driest since
records began in 1836.
figures from the met office show that
only 15.8 millimeters of rain fell on
average up to the 26th of july that's
just 24 of the amount which would be
expected in an average july
experts are warning that if the dry
weather continues it means there will be
a risk of drought with people
potentially being asked to reduce their
water consumption
well to the u.s now and after more than
a year of negotiations a u.s democratic
senator has stunned washington by
announcing a sudden support for
president joe biden's top agenda item a
climate bill senator joe manchin made a
joint statement with senate majority
leader chuck schumer saying they're come
they've come to an agreement on new
legislation addressing health care and
climate change since last year mr
manchin has been using his pivotal vote
in the 50-50 split senate to force
president biden and the democrats to
abandon a more ambitious version of the
bill well joe pike joins me now from
washington dc
joe this is really significant and great
news for the climate
yes and it was chloe it's fair to say a
shock for some a surprise for others and
for climate activists in this country
who've been pretty despondent in recent
months it changes everything it is a big
reset in joe biden's climate
agenda and his ambitions his aims to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions 50 below
2005 at levels by the end of this decade
those aims those targets look almost
achievable with this new bill why well
because we're talking about billions of
dollars of tax incentives incentives to
ramp up the production of wind solar and
geothermal energy incentives to keep
nuclear power stations open but also
incentives for lower income americans to
switch to electric vehicles so why was
it a surprise well as you say it's all
due to uh one man joe manchin this
democrat
senator from west virginia who has been
proving to be a bit of a nightmare for
joe biden a hold out and in this very
finely balanced senate he has refused
to back this until now that of course
has changed it is good news for joe
biden and it also means the u.s can keep
the pressure on other countries like
china and africa to keep up with their
climate change commitments
joe pike in washington for us thanks for
that
now let's get a bit more of the day's
climate news now sections of the world's
largest tropical peatland are being
auctioned today in the democratic
republic of congo
30 oil and gas blocks in the congo basin
which play a crucial role in africa's
climate system are going under the
hammer the move is angering
environmentalists who say oil drilling
poses a significant risk to the
continent already being affected by
climate change
seven people have been killed by
lightning in a village in india's
northern uttar pradesh state it brings
the total death toll by lightning
strikes to 49 people this week indian
officials say lightning has killed
nearly 750 people across the country
since april climate scientists believe
global warming has played a role in the
rising number of lightning strikes with
research suggesting a one degree celsius
rise in temperature increases the
frequency of lightning by 12
a 3.1 million pound tree planting
package has been announced in london it
comes after record-breaking temperatures
and wildfires which destroyed homes and
land in the capital mayor sadiq khan
says last week's events have laid bare
how vulnerable london is to the effects
of climate change
now the national grid has warned that
concerns over gas supplies from russia
could mean periods of uncertainty over
electricity supply this winter although
it says it expects to be able to meet
demand there are renewed calls for the
uk's energy network to reduce its
reliance on gas and shift its focus to
renewable energy
well right now just over half of our
electricity grid is supplied by
renewables that's solar wind and
hydropower while nearly half is gas
and while millions struggle with the
rising cost of living energy giants have
once again been reporting bumper profits
the parent company of british gas
centrica saw half-year operating profits
rise from 262 million pounds to 1.3
billion
meanwhile shell recorded earnings of
around 9.5 billion pounds for the three
months to the end of june more than
double the 4.5 billion pounds for the
same period last year well the firm's
chief executive has been defending the
figures and says shell is now investing
more money into its decarbonisation
strategy
we need to collectively as a society
spend a whole lot more on the transition
and we need to work much harder to
decarbonize the demand for uh
for energy as well and that is exactly
our strategy decarbonizing the demand
for for energy the spending on it steve
we're spending about this year a third
of our combined opex and capex on the
energy transition and we spend about 55
billion dollars a third goes to the
energy transition and if you look at
2025 it will be half so we are
definitely stepping up the the
investments there
well let's talk more about this now
we're joined by jess ralston senior
analyst at the climate and intelligence
unit jess thanks so much for joining us
today we just heard from shell's chief
executive there talking about spending
more money on decarbonisation but still
oil and gas companies are spending more
money on fossil fuels than they are
renewables
hi there yes that's absolutely right so
the fossil fuel industry currently has
plans to build 195 projects that would
each result in at least a billion tons
of co2 over their lifetimes so while
companies like shell and centrica are
investing in renewables there's no doubt
about that their green investments are
simply dwarfed by their fossil fuel
investments
and we have seen a windfall tax
introduced by mr sunap but of course
that's not a permanent solution it's
going to be a really tricky thing for
the next prime minister to navigate
yeah the reality is the oil and gas
companies are making huge amounts of
profit from higher gas prices while the
public could see their energy bills
reach nearly four grand this coming year
so it's easy to understand why the
public think that a windfall tax is a
fair approach but it will be interesting
to see how any prime minister deals with
calls from within their party to scrap
it i mean getting rid of it so quickly
after announcing it does create
uncertainty and you know investors won't
know if they're coming or going so a
longer term solution might be changing
the tax system altogether to make it
less lucrative in the first place for
these companies
and we're all watching the energy crisis
unfold in europe and no doubt wondering
what it means for supplies in the uk
how do you see things panning out here
well like you mentioned earlier national
grid expects to be able to meet our
demand albeit with some periods where
electricity margins are a little bit
tighter because of the uncertainty with
russia
but what we have in the uk is actually a
price problem rather than a security of
supply one like the eu has um you know
we're much less reliant on russian gas
and oil and but that being said although
we're an island we're very tied to what
happens in europe because we're
interconnected with their gas and
electricity markets through our
pipelines so what happens over there to
their prices also happens to ours and
we've seen our gas bills are probably
going to be pushed up by about two grand
by the expensive price of gas and so
until we went ourselves off it for good
we're almost certainly going to feel the
pinch from the volatility in the gas
markets
and while you mentioned it's more of a
price problem than a security problem
the uk still does need to secure its
supply
what do you see happening in the short
to medium term sort of more a bigger
push for renewables
well i think insulating our leaky homes
is probably the most sensible place to
start i mean reducing our energy demand
so we don't have to find and pay for as
much gas is very sensible and it would
help keep us warm this winter and people
are actually really keen to make their
homes more energy efficient you know
they want to save money on bills but
they also want to help with stopping
funding putin's war and in the medium to
longer term i think building out more
homegrown renewables so we need to
import less gas shields us from people
like putin turning on and off the gas
taps when they like to
jess ralston senior analyst at the
climate and intelligence unit thanks so
much for your thoughts on this tricky
subject
now you can get more on this story and
the rest of the week's climate news on
the climate show with tom heap this week
tom will be taking a look at how we need
to adapt our gardening habits to the
changing climate and tom can put your
questions to an expert just scan the qr
code on your screen right now to submit
a question and we'll do our very best to
give you an answer on the climate show
with tom heap on saturday and sunday at
3 30 and 7 30 p.m thanks very much for
joining us today that is all for now